How Hong Kong Built the World's Best Transit
This video is sponsored by Brilliant.
The first 200 to use the link in the description
get 20% off the annual subscription.
On any given weekday, 5.9 million people take
Hong Kong’s public transportation.
Of them, 5.894 million, or 99.9% arrive on
time.
It’s so efficient, so clean and so convenient
that virtually everyone uses it.
If the U.S., with 800 cars per one thousand
people, has a car culture,
Hong Kong, with only 92, has a culture of
public transit.
With the exception of the outlying islands,
there's an easy way to get almost anywhere
in the territory…
On Hong Kong Island, the iconic and only fully
double-decker tram system in the world costs
just 2.3 Hong Kong Dollars, or 30 US Cents.
Nearby, the Peak Tram takes you to the most
spectacular view of the city in just 7 minutes
- a steep 370-meter, or 12,000-foot ascent
that would otherwise take a full hour.
You can cross over to Kowloon on the relaxing
120-year old Star Ferry.
And when you leave Hong Kong, there’s no
need to take your bags to the Airport.
You can drop them in the city, then shop,
eat, explore, and they’ll automatically
be sent to the airport, loaded onto your plane,
and be there waiting for you wherever you
arrive.
There are busses, cable-cars, helicopters,
and the longest outdoor covered escalator
in the world.
Finally, the 12-line, 93-station Mass Transit
Railway, or M-T-R, is responsible for moving
most of the city’s seven and a half million
people.
A special Mickey Mouse themed line goes to
Disneyland, another to the racehorse on event
days, and yet another crosses over into mainland
China.
It’s no wonder more people take the MTR
every single day than the entire population
of Norway or Singapore.
But unlike nearly every other place in the
world, Hong Kong’s public transit pays for
itself.
It’s so profitable that it actually subsidizes
the government - not the other way around.
And its unique business model is an unexpected
window into the city’s ongoing protests.
In most cities around the world, transit is
seen as a public good.
Like building roads or minting coins, busses
and trains are not expected to be profitable.
And while it’s economically useful to get
people to and from where they can make and
spend money, there’s less incentive to make
it clean, quick or comfortable.
The problem is, especially in America, users
of public transit are disproportionately young
and poor.
Which is to say, not politically useful.
In Tucson, Arizona, for example, every third
rider of public transportation is in poverty,
compared to 13% in the general population.
Because of this, it’s treated like social
welfare - mostly for the poor and subsidized
by everyone.
The simple way to measure how much money is
a system loses is to calculate its Farebox
Recovery Ratio - that is, the total amount
made from rides divided by the cost to run
it.
The lowest, meaning least profitable cities
are almost all in the U.S.: Detroit is 20%,
Dallas is 14, and Santa Clara County is 10!
In other words, tickets only pay for one-tenth
of its expenses.
The other 90% is subsidized, reluctantly,
by local, state, and federal governments.
An example of a high ratio is San Francisco's
Bay Area Rapid Transit, at 70% - about the
same as Berlin, Beijing, or Amsterdam.
But then there’s Hong Kong’s MTR.
Fares pay for 185% of its operating expenses,
the highest in the world.
In 2017, it generated 21.4 Billion Hong Kong
Dollars of profit.
And yet, somehow, it’s still extremely affordable.
To get from one side of Hong Kong Island to
the other - from Chai Wan to Kennedy town
- costs just 10.7 HKD or 1.3 US Dollars.
To go all the way from the border with mainland
China to Central is 50.5, or 6.4 US Dollars.
It’s about half that for children, students,
the elderly, and disabled.
There are some obvious reasons Hong Kong has
such a big transportation advantage.
First, as one of the densest places on earth,
with, for example, 57,250 people per square
kilometer, or 22,104 per square mile in the
Kwun Tong district.
Second, its infrastructure is relatively young.
The London Underground opened in 1863, the
New York City Subway in 1904, and Hong Kong’s
MTR in 1979.
But there’s another secret ingredient to
its success.
The MTR is so profitable despite being so
affordable by selling to businesses its biggest
asset: access to the 90% of Hong Kong’s
population that takes the train.
The MTR’s real product is its ability to
almost unilaterally decide where Hong Kongers
go.
Here’s how it works:
First, before construction takes place, the
Hong Kong SAR government grants the company
development rights around new stations.
The MTR pays for the land, but at “greenfield”
prices - meaning, its value before the station
is built.
Then, it builds the new line or station, which,
because of the MTR’s ubiquity, instantly
makes the land in and around it much more
valuable.
Finally, it sells or leases that space to
property developers.
Over 1,400 shops are leased inside stations,
and the areas above and around them are often
partly-owned by or in a profit-sharing agreement
with the MTR.
This includes the first and second tallest
buildings in Hong Kong, the Four Seasons Hotel,
the Ritz Carlton, and about 50 others.
It also attaches MTR-branded malls to popular
stations.
There’s even a 50-high rise, 21,000 apartment,
MTR neighborhood called LOHAS park.
Because of this, it’s quite possible to
unknowingly spend your entire day - sleeping,
eating, shopping, watching a film - without
technically leaving public transit.
It’s called the Rail + Property strategy
and, predictably, it’s very profitable.
In 2018, the company made 8.2 billion HKD
from transit operations - meaning fares - but
12.7 from property development, rent, and
commercial business.
It then gives some of this money back, as
stock dividends, to the government - who owns
75% of the company.
By not relying on government funding, the
MTR can maintain and grow its operations quickly,
as an efficient, market-based company.
The government, meanwhile, sees transit not
as an insatiable money pit but an important
source of income that it’s actively incentivized
to improve.
For example, the MTR is legally required to
report any delay longer than 8 minutes to
the government.
And a 31-minute delay results in a 1 million
HKD fine.
Trains are quiet and clean - with a strict
no eating or drinking policy.
They arrive so often that there is no need
for a timetable.
The Octopus card makes paying as easy as a
single tap - and it also works in convenience
stores, supermarkets, restaurants, vending
machines, laundry machines, even parking meters.
Finally, 75% of the population lives within
one kilometer of a station.
As great as it is, though, there is a catch.
Looking at a map, Hong Kong looks like a tiny
place for 7.5 million people.
But, behind the rows of skyscrapers, visible
from almost anywhere in the territory, are
luscious, green, undeveloped mountains.
Hong Kong is very dense, but the problem isn’t
a lack of space,
Almost three-quarters of its land is green
space.
Only 25% is even developed and a tiny 7% is
residential.
Of course, some of this land is mountainous
and simply can’t be developed but a significant
portion sits un-used or under-used.
For example, the sprawling 420-acre Fanling
golf course is surrounded by rows of cramped
40-floor residential buildings.
There’s a simple economic reason housing
is in such short supply.
To attract businesses, Hong Kong has one of
the lowest income tax rates in the world.
Instead, it makes money from land leases.
Aside from St. John’s Cathedral in Central
which is privately owned by the Church of
England, and a few 999-year leases like the
US Consulate, all land in Hong Kong is government
owned and leased - usually for 50 years.
27% of government revenue comes from land
sales, which means it has little economic
reason to flood the market with more supply,
despite the intense need.
Instead, it constrains supply by slowly auctioning
off land while housing prices continue to
skyrocket.
A tiny 200 square foot studio may cost 4 or
5 million HKD or 600,000 US dollars.
The median annual salary is worth about 12
square feet.
In this way, the MTR corporation and the government,
with their perverse incentives to restrict
land rights and drive up prices, are, in part
responsible for a housing crisis in which
Hong Kongers live in tiny, dirty homes sometimes
about the size of coffins.
Thus, one way or another, Hong Kongers pay
for their world-class public transit.
Not only in the form of inaccessible housing
but also in the control they inadvertently
grant the MTR, and, by extension, the government,
in deciding where and when they can travel.
While fast, cheap, and efficient transit has
enabled millions of Hong Kongers to fight
for their freedom, it has more recently become
a tool to hinder them.
Stations in and around protests are regularly
closed during the weekends, effectively cutting
off most of the population from arriving and
conveniently pinning the blame on protestors
for the interruptions.
It’s a cautionary tale about how indisputably-good
technology can easily be co-opted in the wrong
hands.
The solution, though, is better technology.
When government forces spy on the apps protestors
use to communicate, the solution is to build
a better, more secure and encrypted system.
To protect against facial recognition, we
need to better understand how their neural
networks and machine learning algorithms work.
And those high level skills, in addition to many introductory lessons you can start learning today with Brilliant.
This course will take you from the very basics
of how computers learn, develop your intuition
for why these models work, and build up to
more modern techniques like adversarial models.
In addition to actively learning through solving
fun puzzles, you can also interact with these
ideas as you apply them.
You can use the link in the description to
start learning for free, and the first 200
people will get 20% off the annual premium
subscription, so you can view all Daily Challenges
and unlock dozens of problem-solving courses.
Thanks to Brilliant and to you for watching
this video.